[Music]
when i'm out there riding my bike and i
have this pump on it's almost like it's
not even there
i just feel the freedom of being out
there and feeling the speed and
adrenaline
it's just hanging out there riding her
bike
some might say i'm like dorothy explorer
because i'm always wearing this backpack
but this backpack keeps me alive
[Music]
my name is hannah jordan i'm from tulsa
oklahoma i'm 15 years old and i'm a
competitive cyclist
my long-term goals are to become pro and
be in the olympics in 2020 for tokyo and
bring back the tour de france for women
i have an unknown rare metabolic disease
from when i was very little i was in and
out of the hospital and very sick all
the time and when i was nine they gave
me only a couple months to live
it's like i sort of skipped childhood
my mom took me all over the country to
some specialists and they found a
solution and they gave me a thing called
a g-tube that pumps sugar into my
stomach
it basically keeps my blood sugar at a
normal rate
i've always wanted to do competitive
stuff but for most of my life i couldn't
play sports because of my condition
when i got on the bike it was almost
like my problems weren't there
it's just been like a whole new world
open up to me
this one right here is really special
this was her first one and it's a silver
medal but she'd actually only been
riding a bike two months and then
shortly after that she did this one she
did 101 miles in five hours and 18
minutes which is very very fast
and that's kind of when we realized that
she probably was to be pretty good at
this
this weekend i will be competing in
tulsa tough a three-day race
each day a thousand racers compete from
six different countries around the world
these women are usually 20 and above
my mom and my dad they're my biggest
supporters they take me to all the races
and help me make it in cycling
my mom she helps me get everything ready
and my dad at the 200 meter mark he
starts yelling
it's like a mental marker of like when i
started to sprint
what makes me different from other
cyclists
is the ability to tap in that will power
and determination
i like to tell people it's sort of coded
in my dna to be a fighter
anyone that's been in the hospital for a
long time or has gone through some
struggles or pain or suffering they just
know how to dig deep and tap in and to
be resilient
and even if you lose some days and you
win some others you have to keep getting
back up each and every single time to go
out there and ride your bike
[Music]